antenne de 20h le journal de la
rédaction henri sannier bonsoir et
bienvenue sur le plateau d'antenne 2 à
la une ce soir des milliards sous un
marteau en ce moment au théâtre des
champs elysées à paris se déroule la
vente aux enchères la plus importante
d'après-guerre modigliani bonnart coraux
mathis et sézanne dispersés pour plus de
200 millions de francs c'est une
exclusivité antenne 2
mélodie est libre saines et sauves après
11 jours d'angoissé ravisseurs ont été
neutralisés tôt ce matin trois d'entre
eux sont des français
53 propositions pour lutter contre le
racisme et la discrimination en france
michel hannoun l'auteur du rapport
commandé par le gouvernement s'explique
en direct
l'accord imminent washington sur
réduction du déficit budgétaire
américain la coupe sombre s'élèverait à
75 milliards de dollars en deux ans
compte à rebours pour le 20e tir
d'ariane à bord un satellite allemand le
premier d'un dispositif qui permettra
d'arroser l'europe de programmes
télévisés en direct
une journée supplémentaire de détention
pour marcel carton marcel fontaine
jean paul kauffmann
jean louis normandin d'antenne 2 et
roger auque les otages français au liban
n'ont toujours pas été libérés
l'événement du jour vient donc de
débuter au théâtre des champs-elysées à
paris depuis un peu plus d'un quart
d'heure la collection renan est vendu
aux enchères renom ancien directeur de
la samaritaine avait réuni chez lui
l'une des plus belles collections de
tableaux qui soit au monde des
modigliani des matisse des cézanne des
coraux le catalogue est tellement beau
et prestigieux que tous les record
devrait être battu ce soir george v goût
vous êtes avec nous en direct quelle est
l'ambiance ont dit que le cap des 250
million sera dépassé ce soir et bien si
l'on en croit les toutes premières
ventes qui viennent de s'effectuer à
l'instant un bonnart qui était de donner
à un million vient d'être vendu 1
million 400 mille un bras que vient
d'être vendu 650 milles c'est donc des
prix extraordinaires qui s'annonce ce
soir c'est la troisième vente seulement
et ça ne va nous faire qu'augmenter
c'est un pari considérables engagés
aujourd'hui reconnaître des
champs-elysées par la compagnie des
commissaires-priseurs c'est toute la
révolution de la vie à mystique en
france et du marché de l'art car si nous
voulons faire la concurrence aux marchés
de new york et de londres il faut que
les expériences pareille puisse réussir
hier à francfort encore s'est vendu 1,2
donné à 7 millions actuellement vous
voyez sur l'écran quelques unes des plus
belles toiles qui seront vendus ce soir
notamment ceux mathis la conversation
est un détail du matisse et puis le
chef-d'oeuvre évidemment le modigliani
la belle romaine avec le détail de sa
tête et la femme à la cravate noire qui
sera aussi affichée à 40 millions de
francs alors ce soir vous attendons des
performances considérables nous espérons
qu'elle se réaliseront en direct pendant
le journal henri et vous m'appelez quand
vous voulez tout à fait le risque
georges c'est de voir que certains
plateaux tableau partir à l'étranger les
japonais font fort en ce moment avec le
cours du yen mais aujourd'hui tous les
tableaux qui sont vendus ici sont libres
de quitter la france parce que il y a eu
un accord avec le ministère de la
culture de van gogh ont été l'un donné
l'autre c'est une dation et donc tous
ces tableaux pourront partir à
l'étranger ce qui signifie aussi que le
marché de l'un va pouvoir prendre une
dimension internationale maintenant à
paris merci à tout à l'heure on se
retrouve dans un petit quart d'heure en
espagne la fin du cauchemar mélodie a
été libéré ce matin après 11 jours de
détention la police qui était sur les
traces des ravisseurs depuis quelques
jours a arrêté cinq personnes dont trois
français les policiers sont formels
l'enlèvement de mélodies a été préparé
par sept personnes au moins appartenance
à une bande internationale de
malfaiteurs professionnels mais ce soir
ce soir la première image c'est d'abord
celle de mélodies dans les bras de ses
parents roland sicard
le cauchemar vient de prendre fin après
11 jours de détention la petite mélodie
a retrouvé les siens onze jours pendant
lesquels les ravisseurs ont plusieurs
fois menacé d'assassiner la fillette
11le pendant lesquelles la famille ne
pouvait qu un temps
de 2 des parents des gens qui ont été
kidnappés c'est c'est pire que que
presque la main nous ma femme et moi si
on a si on n'avait pas
eu mais le dire aujourd'hui ou demain je
passerai devenue folle pendant toute la
durée de la détention l'espagne a vécu
au rythme d'un véritables marchandages
dont l'objet était minutes les
malfaiteurs réclament est au départ une
rançon de 13 millions de dollars 78
millions de francs une somme que raymond
à cacher on ne pouvait réunis comme dans
une vente aux enchères les prix ont
alors baissé 5 puis 4 puis 2 millions de
dollars et c'est finalement à cause de
cette rançon que les policiers ont pu
remonter la piste des ravisseurs un
portefeuille perdu par un des
malfaiteurs dans lequel les enquêteurs
ont retrouvé le brouillon de la demande
de rançon il ne restait plus qu à
localiser le propriétaire ce matin
l'assaut a été donné melody a été
séquestrée dans cette maison au sud de
l'espagne cinq malfaiteurs dont deux
français ont été arrêtés des
renseignements fournis par la police
française permettront peut-être de
retrouver la trace des derniers
ravisseurs de la petite mélodie
depuis cet après midi on connaît
l'essentiel des mesures qui figurent
dans le rapport annuel le rapport
hanoune qui porte le nom d'un député rpr
de l'isère est consacrée au racisme et
aux discriminations en france le
document contient 53 propositions il
suggère un renforcement de la
législation antiraciste et la création
d'un haut conseil de l'immigration
bernard pradines au le rapport de
monsieur hanoune fait 53 propositions
pour mieux intégrer les immigrés à
l'école dans la ville dans le travail et
pour combattre ce que le député appelle
le racisme tranquille à l'école plus de
classe pour les enfants étrangers et
dans le même temps développement de
l'enseignement des droits de l'homme
pour tous la culture d'une façon
générale doit tenir compte de celles de
nos voisins immigrés et la télévision en
particulier doit y être mieux associés
l'intégration passe également par
l'amélioration des conditions de
logement et d'emploi mais l'accueil
n'est pas seulement économique
l'administration doit veiller au respect
de l'égalité de traitement entre
nationaux et immigrés l'islam car le
rapport se préoccupe surtout des
musulmans doit être une religion comme
les autres quant au racisme quotidien
selon le rapporteur il devrait être
sanctionné plus sévèrement
enfin la création d'un haut conseil de
l'immigration pourrait permettre à la
tolérance d'être réellement une valeur
en hausse pour citer monsieur hanoune
michel hannoun bonsoir vous êtes avec
nous en direct de grenoble il avait
vraiment urgence en la matière et il y
avait certainement urgence à des
passionnés à débat qui est un débat
difficile qui inquiète qui divise est
qui et qui passionne c'est l'honneur de
monsieur malhuret au nom du gouvernement
d'avoir confié cette mission est
maintenant que j'ai terminé je pense
qu'il avait effectivement urgence à des
passionnés que l'on sache qu'il ya des
racistes en france c'était le cas mais
que l'on sache que la france n'est pas
raciste je crois que c'est important a
constaté est à dire oui c'était presque
une mission impossible qu'on vous a
confiée
aujourd'hui beaucoup disent que vous en
tirez d'ailleurs assez honorablement
vous avez fait comment pour appréhender
le problème en trois mois seulement
écoutez j'ai d'abord était concret j'ai
d'abord été près des réalités je suis
allé rencontrer tout ce que la france
compte ou à peu près de responsables
d'associations de partis politiques mais
aussi je suis allé tout bêtement est
tout simplement sur le terrain au
contact des réalités et des gens parce
que eux sentent bien comment les choses
se passent dans leur vie quotidienne et
ils n'ont pas là la passion bien souvent
que l'on rencontre à d'autres niveaux
oui le le maître mot du rapport c'est
l'intégration jusqu'à présent je vais me
faire un peu l'avocat du diable mais bon
ça n'avait pas été spécialement réussi
un
l'intégration ça demande des efforts
l'effort de l'étranger qui vit en france
et qui doit s'intégrer et puis l'effort
de la france pour l'accueillir c'est un
effort réciproque et qui demande du
temps qui demande aussi des efforts et
je crois vraiment que nous sommes en
phase de prêt à relever ce défi qui se
pose aujourd'hui qui ne concerne pas que
le gouvernement mais qui concerne
l'ensemble des français médias compris à
une question plus pointus ce que vous
proposez correspond grosso modo aux
idées de la majorité actuellement en
place ça correspond aux idées de la
majorité des français et je pense que la
majorité est représentative de la
majorité des français je crois que
vraiment le travail de en profondeur or
de toute passion hors de tout clivage
parce que le racisme n'est ni de droite
ni de gauche que j'ai essayé de faire
est de nature au moins à rassembler sur
l'essentiel des propositions c'est en
tous les cas ma conviction dernière
question vous ne craignez pas que ce
rapport soit abandonnée au fond d'un
placard comme d'autres rapports dont on
a beaucoup parlé il a au moins le mérite
de faire un constat un constat clair qui
peut rassembler les français il a aussi
je crois le mérite d'apporter des
réponses très ponctuel très précise très
concrète et qui peuvent immédiatement ou
à à plus ou moins long terme être mise
en un mais je répète ça ne concerne pas
que le gouvernement ça concerne les
médias ça concerne le grand public ça
concerne vous et moi en quelque sorte
tout sans apport bonsoir et merci
d'avoir répondu à nos questions deuxième
et dernière journée de voyage pour
jacques chirac sur l'île de la réunion
après avoir vigoureusement pris à partie
gouvernement de gauche qui se sont
succédé le premier ministre a déclaré
aujourd'hui qu'il fallait s'appuyer sur
les départements et territoires
d'outre-mer pour porter le message
humaniste et universel de la france
reportage de notre envoyé spécial jean
louis le scène le premier ministre se
serait intéressé aujourd'hui à
l'économie du sud du département
notamment un dossier qui lui tient à
coeur l'agriculture mais il n'a pas pour
autant négligé la dimension politique de
son voyage à la réunion devant le
député-maire du tampon un proche de
raymond barre il a insisté sur sa vision
de l'union de la majorité à sa manière
une union dans laquelle chacun doit
avoir la juste place qui lui revient tel
soit mesurée à l'aune de ses mérites du
poids démographique ou électorale ou
économiques qu'ils représentent cette
unité doit s'exprimer à chacune des
échéances qui sont devant nous l'an
prochain où il est essentiel qu'un
candidat issu de la majorité soit élu à
la suite des élections présidentielles
sans qu'aucune voix ne lui fasse défaut
au second tour de ces élections et dans
les échéances ultérieures
départementales ou législatives pour
lesquelles le succès de la majorité
nationale qui supportent cet effort de
redressement passe également ici comme
ailleurs par l'on tente entre ceux qui
dirigent ou qui sont responsables de
cette majorité à chacun ses mérites
d'une formule qui a dû teintées
bizarrement aux oreilles de raymond
barre qui voit venir prochainement dans
son département d'origine
françois mitterrand fera également le
voyage de la réunion janvier et nul
doute que jacques chirac reviendra ici
avant les présidentielles cette fois en
candidat en s'attaquant au bilan social
nice qui hier en demandant aujourd'hui
qu'on le juge sur son action et qu'on
lui permette de la poursuivre après 88
il a déjà donné le ton de sa propre
campagne la déprime toujours de mise sur
les marchés financiers nouvelle baisse
de 2,51 % aujourd'hui à la bourse de
paris apparemment les signaux
contradictoires envoyés hier par
washington sur l'imminence d'un accord
entre le congrès et la maison blanche
n'avait rien arrangé cet après midi
enfin l'éclaircie dans la tempête on
vient d'apprendre que la rrq or allaient
être conclue sur la base d'une réduction
de 75 milliards de dollars du déficit
budgétaire américain en deux ans
précision importante confirmation à
washington avec jacques à bouchard une
négociation marathon 4 semaines de
tractations entre l'équipe de la maison
blanche et les élus du congrès des
réunions interminables pour un objectif
jugé modeste réduire de 75 milliards de
dollars le gouffre budgétaire américain
en 1988 89 un des négociateurs voulant
détendre l'atmosphère interrogée la
boule de cristal billère pour savoir si
le compromis était possible pourtant
jour après jour ronald regan poussé
porte-parole multiplié les déclarations
rassurantes
en fait les pourparlers buter sur des
obstacles de taille les crédits
militaires par exemple la présidence ne
voulait pas qu'on dit ou pas question
non plus de renier sur les retraites des
personnes âgées il augmenter massivement
les impôts ce à quoi ronald reagan
s'était toujours refusée l'impératif
pour les deux parties étaient 200 tentes
pour rassurer wall street est orienté à
la baisse
redonner un peu de tonus aux marchés
financiers qui ne s'est toujours pas
remis du choc du 19 octobre le fameux
lundi noir l'accord dit on maintenant
est acquis et sera confirmé dans
quelques heures de toute façon les
négociateurs n'avaient plus le choix en
cas d'impasse le couperet serait tombé à
minuit avec une loi prévoyant 23
milliards de dollars de prélèvements
automatiques dans les dépenses publiques
aussi bien civils que militaires pour
1988 philippe ça si on a tellement dit
que tout dépendait de cet accord
américain que maintenant on se prend à
rêver c'est la fin de nos malheurs il
est bien trop tôt ou encore henry pour
dire si tous nos malheurs sont finis
mais en tout cas on peut pousser un ouf
de soulagement faute d'accord les
marchés risqués de connaître de la
semaine prochaine un nouveau 6
aujourd'hui il est du reste très nerveux
la bourse de paris a fortement chuter
wall street à l'ouverture perdait 40
points et le dollar enregistré un
nouveau recul quand la bourse de new
york a appris qu'un accord était en vue
elle s'est mise à remonter et
actuellement elle est orientée à la
hausse pour nous français cet accord
signifie deux choses d'abord le dollar
devrait se stabiliser peut-être même un
petit peu remonté et ainsi soulager le
franc français qui souffrent de la
hausse du marc deuxièmement la bourse de
paris devrait se calmer et reprendre ses
esprits et danger cependant ne sont pas
loin de là tous et loyers maintenant il
faut préparer une réunion internationale
afin de parvenir une meilleure
coopération économique entre les pays
occidentaux il reste encore du chemin à
faire mais une étape difficile a été
franchi incontestablement à paris au
palais bourbon les députés étudient un
projet de loi qui devrait faciliter la
reprise des entreprises projets
importants et dont l'urgence c'est de
plus en plus évidente car un chef
d'entreprise sur deux a plus de 50 ans
autre statistique éloquente 700 mille
chefs d'entreprise ou sept cent mille
entreprises françaises plutôt devront
trouver un repreneur dans les dix ans
qui viennent comment se préparer à de
telles échéances et bien sachez qu'il
existe désormais une école de repreneurs
d'entreprises elle a été inaugurée ce
matin par alain madelin le ministre de
l'industrie c'est à laval
reportage patrick boitet et franck
brisset
la situation était tendue en début
d'année à l'imprimerie barnéoud de laval
une pme de 50 personnes le patron
partait à la retraite et aucun de ces
enfants ne voulait du poste et
l'entreprise avait bien fait une
proposition de rachat mais avec le
licenciement de la moitié du personnel
trois caps de l'entreprise ont alors
décidé de se jeter à l'eau et de
reprendre la société seulement personne
n'avait la compétence nécessaire sommes
donc trois personnes qui veulent
complémentaires la comptable un chef
d'atelier mois anciennement secrétaire
général aucun de nous trois on avait une
vision globale de l'entreprise il
fallait donc que quelqu'un puisse avoir
cette ouverture complète sur l'extérieur
et en l'occurrence on essaie de
concerter le plus jeune katia est
retenue pour tourner à l'école l'école
c'est l'école des managers de laval une
première en france un établissement
destiné aux repreneurs d'entreprises
responsables de leur société ou
repreneurs externes ils viennent
d'apprendre ici tous les rouages d'une
paix m et si j'ai tout découvert pour
moi la reprise d'entreprise je la voyais
gérer de façon très aléatoire
avec l'école je me suis totalement remis
en question regardez finance marketing
stratégie globale l'école dispense deux
mois de cours théoriques obligatoire la
reprise d'entreprise ne s'improvise pas
un tiers d'entre elles échouent par
manque de compétence des repreneurs
bénéfices ce sont généralement des
spécialistes qui connaissent un métier
le maîtrise or pour réussir dans une
autre reprise d'entreprise il faut être
un généraliste et l'objectif de l'école
de manager c'est justement de les former
à des domaines de fonctionnement
d'entreprises qui ne connaissent pas
pour qu'ils soient capables de les
appréhender et réellement de réussir
leur reprise non donc par la nouvelle
mais la plus grande innovation de
l'école concerne le suivi des stagiaires
pendant un an et demi ceux ci pourront
faire appel aux consultants de l'école
pour traiter les problèmes particuliers
de leur entreprise coût total de la
formation cinquante mille francs mais
pour ce prix à l'imprimerie barnéoud on
reprend espoir en l'avenir de la société
l'actualité en direct retour au théâtre
des champs elysées à paris où nous
allons assister à la mise en vente
hier à 10,6 une aquarelle à
1300 villes tout à fait à gauche trois
cent mille
trois cent mille
4 millions 700 mille la mise à prix 1
million est actuellement la vente
continue nous venons d'assister aux
records pour l'instant c'est un tableau
de coraux le portrait de madame chat
mouillé qui mise à prix à 2 millions a
atteint 5 million deux cent mille
généralement les enchères dure combien
de temps aux ordres alors les enchères
dure entre une minute et demie et quatre
minutes pas plus assez vite pour
l'instant mais ce qu'il faut dire c'est
que ici on est en duplex avec tokyo il y
a aussi une cinquantaine de lignes
téléphoniques qui relie le monde entier
au théâtre des champs elysées et ça va
très très les modigliani c'est pas pour
tout de suite alors mobivia lycée pour
un petit peu plus tard je pense vers 22
heures ok mais je vous rappelle quand
même il faut avant la fin de cette
édition merci à tout à l'heure on
enchaîne avec les télégrammes de
l'étranger ils sont commentés ce soir
par isabelle style
l'opposition se mobilise à santiago deux
cent mille manifestants réclament des
élections libres à quelques mois du
plébiscite présidentielle le général
pinochet se déclare fera quitter le
pouvoir si le choix des électeurs lui
est défavorable
aide d'urgence à l'ethiopie la
communauté européenne débloque 70
millions de francs pour lutter contre la
famine elle menace près de 4 millions
d'éthiopiens 600 mille tonnes de
céréales sont nécessaires la cee a déjà
fourni un quart des besoins
bientôt un nouveau vaccin contre le sida
où jaillit il a été mis au point fin des
chercheurs français et zaïrois qui sera
testé sur un millier de militaires à
kinshasa un soldat sur 8 sur les
séropositifs côté population le chiffre
avancé de 12%
les américains a découvert une
délégation ce défi qu'un fait une usine
de destruction d'armes chimiques dans
l'utah but de la visite renforcer la
confiance entre les deux pays dans
l'attenté d'un traité les états unis
sortiront bientôt la première arme
chimique nouvelle génération
l'europe de la télévision sur les
épaules d'ariane si tout va bien cette
nuit à 3h19 très exactement ariane
mettra sur orbite le premier satellite
ouest allemand de télévision en direct
succès obligatoire car derrière se
profile déjà le programme français avec
tf1 et tu élèves de jacques violet 7
mètres de haut plus de deux tonnes
bourrés d'électronique tv sat est le
premier maillon technique de la
télévision directe européenne sa
puissance est telle qu'il permettra aux
allemands d'abord mais aussi à quelques
voisins de recevoir des programmes
directement dans chaque foyer avec une
petite antenne d'environ 50 cm et un
décodeur
l'ensemble ne devrait pas coûter plus
cher qu'un bon magnétoscope ce satellite
est le premier d'une même famille de
quatre deux allemands et deux français
tdf 1 et 2 qui seront placés
progressivement au dessus de l'europe
pour desservir 100 millions de
téléspectateurs
ce programme permettra également
d'expérimenter en vraie grandeur une
nouvelle norme de télévision haute
définition le des deux mc c'est à dire
une image de télévision aussi nette que
celle des salles de cinéma une norme
internationale
compatible avec le des deux mc vient
d'ailleurs d'être reconnue aujourd'hui
comme norme officielle européenne pour
1990 alors que japonais et américains
tentaient d'imposer d'autres standards
pour remplacer le palais le sait qu'anne
une espèce d'armistice dans cette guerre
des télévisions haute définition
c'est donc sous les meilleurs auspices
que tv sat sera lancée une chance pour
les industriels européen de
l'électronique grand public
après la télévision la radio nouvelle
affaire sur la bande fm mais cette fois
ci à lyon hier soir on apprenait
l'inculpation pour abus de biens sociaux
de pierre alberti le pdg de radio
nostalgie cet après midi le secrétaire
de la fédération du parti socialiste du
rhône a été entendu comme témoin les
deux hommes s'étaient connus il y a
quelques années lors de l'attribution
des fréquences la sphère radio nostalgie
est une affaire complexe sur laquelle la
brigade financière du srpj de lyon
enquêtait depuis 11 mois déjà pascal
deschamps
lorsqu'ils font des choses rencontre
pierre alberti il dirige à villeurbanne
radio liberty 69 dont la haute autorité
décidant 84 le regroupement avec
nostalgie sur la bande fm si radio 69
n'existe plus aujourd'hui le juge
fennecs souhaite apparemment en savoir
plus sur les relations publicitaire
qu'entretenaient les deux radios pour
charles hernu yvon deschamps n'a rien à
se reprocher je veux dire c'est que pour
moi
yvon deschamps c'est un homme honnête
en ce moment même si je suis bien
renseigné il est entendu comme témoin
cela veut dire que il n'a même pas de
défense auprès de lui nous en sommes là
alors j'espère que ce en restera là
une dizaine de témoins entendus 5
inculpation trois incarcérations la
sphère nostalgie fait grand bruit au
centre pierre alberti le bûcheron devenu
milliardaire voitures de luxe château
est un réseau de 135 radio les
enquêteurs se sont d'abord intéressée à
la faillite de son entreprise de
démolition 20 millions de francs de
pertes puis c'est la destination de
recettes publicitaires jamais recouvré
par les régies de radio nostalgie ce
soir son avocat contre attaque il n'y a
rien dans le dossier qui justifie la
mise en détention le juge en a pour le
moment décidé autrement
l'adieu à jacques anquetil s'était
aujourd'hui à la cathédrale de rouen des
personnalités beaucoup d'anonymes sont
venus rendre un dernier hommage à l'ami
et aux champions thierry blancot
maillot jaune posé sur son cercueil
cathédrale entièrement fleuri de lys
blancs
eddy merckx
poulidor guy marc darrigade ocaña entre
autres
l'hommage des grands du cyclisme de la
politique et de la presse
compagnons d'échappée ou anciens
adversaires tous unis une heure plus
tard au cimetière de quincampoix pour
conduire jacques anquetil à sa dernière
demeure et reprendre en choeur les mots
du père larcher est pas mort jacques tu
es juste partie devant je rappelle que
ce soit en exclusivité dans le journal
de l'a2 dans le journal de 20h nous
assistons à la vente de quarante trois
tableaux en direct du théâtre des
champs-elysées à paris c'est la vente la
plus importante depuis 1945 est ce que
les records ont été battus au genre vous
êtes toujours en direct
alors le voici maintenant avec le
tableau de marque celle gros maire qui
est présenté et qui va être proposé à la
vente dans quelques instants par le
président des commissaires priseurs
monsieur milon voici le tableau de
marcel gromaire
alors cinq cent mille cinq cent mille
cinquante mille six cent mille
sept cent mille sept cent mille enchères
et y avait le record pour l'instant j'ai
le record est toujours détenu par le
tableau de coraux à cinq millions huit
cent mille nous avons une très très
belle vente tout à l'heure d'un put
fille à 900000 nous avons dans
l'ensemble un enfant assis de coraux à 3
millions sans honte triple à peu près
les ventes ou bien pour certains autres
ont gagné un tiers du prix annoncés
pendant les enchères c'est je pense
qu'on va dépasser les 200 millions
prévus oui c'est une vente importante
george qui perd vient paris se
positionner par rapport aux places
fortes américaines et anglaises aux
galeries sotheby's christie's pour ne
pas les citer mais maintenant toutes les
villes du monde toutes les capitales ont
des marchés de l'art très important et
on espère aussi que messieurs monsieur
balladur va faire un effort en vertu de
ses ventes parce que
la france est le pays le plus taxé on
pense 7% sur les jours les ventes et
ensuite on prend 4 % de plus-value ce
qui fait beaucoup pour les acheteurs et
vous savez que ici à au théâtre des
champs elysées on paye ton temps les
étoiles qu'on a fait et ça fait des
dépenses considérables on sait très bien
que on les très fortunés quand on achète
des poils pareil et souvent ce sont des
sociétés et notamment des sociétés
japonaises mais tout de même une forte
attention à tout ce qui les concerne les
impôts mais j'ose pas l'image il
a un million six cent mille le grand
mère vient d'être adjugée devant vous
merci c'était en direct ça fait rêver un
tir est oui alors à moins de gagner au
tiercé aux cartes et la transition est
facile je crois qu'il va falloir obtenir
ses clio ring quelquefois plus cher bien
cherché placé pour le savoir je n'ai pas
acheté mais j'étais dans la région de
deauville très souvent ce libre aux
pronostics pour le tiercé de vincennes
mais après midi sur l'hippodrome de
vincennes une course au 3t longue de
2650 mètres qui réunit 19 concurrents
des trotteurs âgés de 4 ans alors ces
chevaux sont déjà très connue de nous
puisque vous avez l'habitude de les
jouer au stick de course voici toutefois
ce que je vous conseille de jouer dans
mon pronostic lost et le numéro 10 rue
dans le xiii royal du doigt loose wrp la
halle 6 rocagel saint cricq lui le neuf
rozier d'armes dont le 17 et rose de
beauvoisin de 14 10 13 11 6 5 9 17 et 14
merci et bon week-end météo égale
fraîcheur laurent moment là la fraîcheur
sera la dominante de notre météo pour
les ce congé de fin de semaine qui nous
arrive une mère vous allez voir tout de
suite les images satellites n'ont pas
les images et inite la couleur du temps
telle que vous la propose des images à
thé ne veulent pas dire grand chose en
ce moment il ya beaucoup trop de brume
alors vous allez voir les dominantes en
trois coups de pinceau sur le littoral
méditerranéen du soleil mais aussi
beaucoup de vent un vent qui souffle et
cet après midi à 187 km heure du côté de
du cap corse et demain il soufflera 80
90 km heure fort heureusement il se
calme nous aurons demain également une
tendance disons nuageuse un peu plus
poussée sur les côtes littorales cette
fois atlantique partout ailleurs ne font
pas dans le détail de nos régions
alternance de nuages et d'éclaircies de
rares ondées mais il y en aura la
couleur du temps maintenant non la
couleur du ciel annoncé on a passé des
températures plus exactement les
températures pour la journée de demain 6
à 12 degrés sur la moitié nord elles
sont à la baisse nous aurons huit à
quatre sur la moitié sud et il fera 7
degrés à cateau cambrésis c'est là où
est né mathis 14° à aix en provence
c'est là où est né cézanne et 8 degrés à
auvers-sur-oise c'est là que repose van
gogh et il fera 7 degrés à talant en
côte d'or est célèbre pour ses peintres
les peintres de talent alors que demain
est bien le soleil se lèvera à 8h09 se
couchera 17h03 et ce sera la
présentation à marquer et il avait bien
préparé son qu elle avait jeté un coup
d'oeil sur le conducteur prochain
rendez-vous d'information 23h05 avec
aubry et de l'air pendant le week-end
vous retrouverez daniel bilalian et
philippe gassot demain 13h15 n'oubliez
pas l'assiette anglaise présenté par
bernard ap ce soir à 21h30 mention
particulière à bernard pivot pour la
600e d' apostrophes qui vont nous a
promis une petite surprise attendons
tout à l'heure excellent week-end sur
antenne 2 je vous retrouve lundi bonsoir